big shot I remember reading the story
was you went out with Bianca Jagger and
she was either saying to you you're a
big shot or you were saying to her well
that I know where that story came from I
went out to dinner with Mick Jagger uh
and he was with Bianca at the time he
was married to her and he was writing a
song uh working so hard to keep you in
luxury you know that song working so
hard and she was kind of putting on the
rits a little bit and he was he he I
think he was kind of bugged with the
whole bit he'd had it with her yeah and
then um that's I was thinking of him
singing that to Bianca Jagger not me oh
so he had to be a big
shot oh so that was MC Jagger M and he's
saying to your wife you're you don't you
went up toown riding in your limousine
if F par you clo you know I just picture
in Mick singing it